good to see you old friend good to see
you old friend so it's like very hot now
you know what this is an unusual day
it's been on the cooler side and then
today suddenly out of the blue it just
feels Harvick 98 degrees yeah it is it
98 degrees 90 degrees plus there's a
drought on I mentioned that or I'm doing
what I can why are you yelling at me
I did what I didn't think I was yelling
yeah yeah I'm you seem pretty hydrated
to me no I'm doing everything I can I've
cut back on the watering really yeah I
almost completely stopped masturbating
in the shower
boken car yeah of the LA drought do you
think so of girl just spoken cause the
allegro does people masturbating in the
shower
of course explain that what do you mean
you've masturbated in the shower
everyone masturbates in the shower
takes time it adds to the amount of
water that's being used with women do it
too with the massagers it's going on
it's happening and no one wants to talk
you out at the massager
I didn't know that that was just for
women oh I like it
I think we all learned a little
something here tonight we learned a lot
don't waste water
right no but so so you stop because if
you're in the shower and you're doing
that it does take it takes it takes time
especially you can't really bring video
elements into the shower and you got to
kind of go with your old your memory and
that takes longer unless you're right
there you know like from that day like
that morning yeah too much information I
think yeah likes it yeah it's a whole
Bandstand of [ __ ] right yeah
that was the original name of the band
we had to change it yeah hey thanks for
watching please subscribe to my youtube
channel so they will stop making me
shoot these videos please